wenn du wissen willst wie der Herbst
schmeckt dann mach dieses Pilzrisotto m
ohne Witz schmeckt wie bei meiner m und
das hier ist alles was wir brauchen wir
beginnen aber mit ein bisschen Butter
die gebe ich einfach in einen Topf zum
schmilzen Teilchen beseschleuniger wir
müssen die auf überscheilgeschwindigkeit
beschleunigen und wenn unsere Butter
geschmolzen ist geben wir ein paar
Schalotten fein gewürfelt dazu bisschen
glasig werden lassen Knoblauch hinterher
hier habe ich ein paar Steinpilze m
smells like autum dann kommt auch unser
risottooreis dazu und den rösten wir ein
bisschen mit an bis er glasig ist wenn
der Reis ein bisschen glasig ist geben
wir unseren Weißwein dazu löschen das
Ganze ab das löst die Röster rum vom
Topfboden wenn der Wein jetzt verkocht
ist dann geben wir unsere Brühe drauf
Zack und es riecht wunderschön herbstig
jetzt bringen wir das einmal zum Kochen
und stellen es dann auf mittlere Hitze
das Resort hat eine schöne Konsistenz
und um es jetzt noch schlotzig zu
bekommen reiben wir jede Menge Parmesan
hinein Parmesan den und unterrühren noch
mehr das ist eine schöne Konsistenz
fertig ist unser Risotto